hello folks welcome to rational science
we had a great day today the other day I
talked about the fact that I turned 70.
seven decades I hope everybody can hear
me okay please let me know otherwise
okay I'll see if I can keep one eye my
right eye on uh your comments as much as
possible anyways I turned 70 the other
day I said that and
um
I was researching uh the plantagenets
the uh Kings of England
these days and uh you know there was not
one of them that reached the age of 70.
uh the one that reached the highest was
Elizabeth the first he reached the she
reached the age of 69.
and then it wasn't until George II 76
and his son George III 81 that was uh
already going into the 18th to 19th
century but before then you know people
really died relatively early and not
always in battles you know it was like
old age was like 49 54 you know people
died at those ages
so I guess in that sense we can consider
ourselves lucky today that a lot of
people live to the age of 80 you know so
we have long lives okay we've managed to
extend the lives of individual humans
anyways one fellow I complained about
arthritis the other day when fella made
a comment about that he says if you want
healthier fingers
consider the difference between the
animal oils and plant oils clocks don't
magically age you by ticking
okay the clock does not make me age okay
yeah I got it and uh oxidative uh
oxidative stress ages you and in every
case of stress your body while it's
still alive is trying to heal itself
you know we have all these experts today
everybody's an expert in um
in medicine
and in politics because it's all
opinions
so everybody is an expert on their own
opinion yeah uh you know the way I look
at it uh this uh
arthritis isn't a disease or ailment you
could say of old age okay it's uh old
animals like me that catch arthritis
some catch arthritis others catch you
know diabetes uh cancer you know those
are all diseases or ailments of old age
and I think a lot of that has to do with
the fact that we're living to Greater
extent today one and the other one is
that
um
you know genetics uh I think it's got a
lot to do with the fact that we've been
inbreeding for the last 200 300 000
years there is uh today no uh important
no relevant
um genetic difference between any human
we're all clones pretty much in many
ways uh so whoever you marry that's your
sister and vice versa you know girl
marries her brother uh so I think that's
got a lot to do with these problems and
also why we have
um some of the problems that you see out
there like homosexuality and um autism a
lot of kids being born with with those
things and I think it's got a lot to do
with the fact that we've been inbreeding
for so many centuries thousands of years
really and these are the results and I
talked about that in the past a little
bit the Amish you know they've been
inbreeding for Less only 350 years they
started out with what like 3500 today
they're a thousand times as many there
are 350
000 today uh 100 times that's it
um and they all came from that original
stock
and they're having problems today as
well they're being born with six fingers
okay so I think inbreeding has a lot to
do with it and inbreeding leads to
problems genetic problems and I think
that's what we're seeing today in our
populations
anyways
um
uh here's uh the Russians the Duma which
is the Russian Congress talking about
homosexuality they decided to do a
little more than just uh Bennett for
propaganda for kids now they don't want
it even as propaganda for adults okay
and so here we have uh one note from the
BBC it says Russia pass this answer to
blinken gay propaganda law they call it
the answer to blinking because blinken's
Secretary of State he said
um that it was designed to censor people
okay and so Russia essentially bans the
propaganda of non-traditional sexual
relations
categorizes any positive depictions of
same-sex uh relationships in mass media
or advertising under the same umbrella
as Distributing pornography the
promotion of violence or stoking racial
ethnic and religious tensions Ban's
advertising of anything related to LGBT
prohibits discussions unlearned about
LGBT topics and the sale of goods with
LGBT slogans or symbols anyone who
breaks the law will face a fine of up to
6600 bucks and companies can face up to
82 000 books foreigners and stateless
people rispian in prison or expelled
from Russia if they do not comply
um I think there's a lot of uh Christian
denomination
in the west which would like to include
that in the U.S Constitution if they
could you know
so I don't think it's just the Russians
you know but we have uh we do have a
polarized World in that sense we have
the uh American Empire and all its
colonies and they've already
accepted homosexuality and promoted in
fact and the other side the Russians the
Arabs I don't know exactly about the
Chinese or the Indians but in general
the other parts of the world uh Africans
you know the whole continent uh they're
not too much in favor of that in fact
some countries still punish it uh by
hanging or death Iran hanged a couple
homosexuals sometime back saw the news
so uh you know you have this
this by world this uh bipolar world
we'll see what happens with all that as
time goes by anyways I'm gonna start
Extinction today with my a little uh I
guess you could say it's a uh summary
uh historical summary of how I see the
progress of the global economy okay
we went slowly for many centuries and
then uh what we did was
um
uh last 200 years you could say
uh global economic
um uh the the growth right and the the
total economic output uh has grown
balloon exponentially uh
thanks to First manufacturing and today
to you could say Services even though uh
Services again is abstraction it's
nothing
it's uh
I call it unemployment
okay so anyone who is doing Services is
doing unemployment anyways here's my uh
five cent worth on it in uh one uh
little strip there one little uh
uh video and let me turn this on here it
goes
good economic growth evolves slowly
since the start of civilization going
from agriculture to industrialization
and ballooning into services but we
can't grow demographically and
economically forever the balloon is
going to pop
and man is destined to fade into
Oblivion
no civilization of intelligent beings in
the universe will ever know that we were
ever here
the Earth will continue to spin and the
moon will continue to run around it
until the sun swallows both of them and
the universe will continue on as if
nothing that's the Fate that awaits us
that was the fate of all civilizations
that ever evolved anywhere in the
universe
so that's my 10 cents worth
okay
um
this is what I think we're doing today
this is where we're at okay again a
quick summary
and it's that uh we have so many people
today that
um
uh you know are in the service economy I
would say about 85 percent in
industrialized or Advanced Nations and
those same countries have only about one
percent of agriculture meaning uh both
in labor and in GDP okay so these
numbers more or less reflect also the
labor force and you know what we're
doing we're scratching each other's
backs you know one guy saying the other
one uh acts the other one does internet
and so we're doing all these services
that are really
unproductive in the sense they don't
produce anything tangible all we're
doing with that is just again scratching
each other's backs and passing the money
around that's all we're doing only when
that money goes into agriculture which
is in by agriculture I mean anything
that produces food it could be fishing
uh cattle ranching whatever the point
here is all that money goes into some of
that ends up in agriculture and thanks
to that agriculture we are alive and we
can continue rolling around in circles
okay
uh but you know what happens if uh you
know at some point money disappears
and uh the agriculturalists do not
accept money anymore
but what happens then
well I think uh what happens then the
whole chain collapses okay so now
suddenly we don't have anyone producing
or Distributing food to the cities to
the people who do services and the whole
thing collapses now you might say well
why would money collapse to zero
well
I can give you my five cents worth again
I'm saying money will collapse to zero
because it's being not only you devalued
every day but if you look at the last 30
40 decades okay for addicted I'm sorry
40 years right uh you will find that uh
the worker the proletariat the person
who depends on a salary uh his income
has decreased in value over time yes we
live comfy uh a lot more comfortable
than the ancient Egyptian pharaohs you
know they didn't have a pillow they
didn't have a bathroom with a shower
they didn't have uh you know a fridge to
cool their beer
um so we live better but at the same
time all we're doing is more and more
people are just making it dirty to the
end of the month they're living one
paycheck to the next
and a lot of that has to do with the
fact that money is being devalued and
right now we're talking about inflation
meaning again money is losing its value
and you're worried about the United
States dollar you should see other
countries that depend on the dollar
their money is being devalued even
faster than the dollar and the question
is how long can we continue devaluating
coins around the world
currencies right
until we get to a point where nobody
accepts it
because you know what happens uh you
it's not uh like you know the poorest
people
um get uh lower and lower on the scale
in order for them not to go out into the
streets and you know break windows and
Burn Tires the governments what they're
doing is subsidizing them giving them
money
so that they reach the end of the month
barely but reach the end of the month so
these people you know a lot of them
don't don't even have jobs or have semi
jobs like selling you know something on
the streets and so here they are you
know they're they're trying to survive
and the government is helping those
people and as long as those people are
helped you know they don't go out and do
bad things out there but where's the
government where are the governments
getting their money from
and the answer is from God and they just
put the little machine to work and they
put pull out the dollars or whatever
money currencies they have
and that's what's happening and I'm not
sure you can continue that forever okay
now one person has a solution thank God
we have some economists that come here
and Pitch their uh their ideas and
here's one probably he's got a great
idea he says uh we just create new money
instead of green money why don't we
propose Brown money you know I mean
after all money it's just money right so
as a nation group where people could
start printing their own new money that
will kick-start the economy Kickstart
economy because you print new money uh
-huh you know how many times we pray and
do what yeah they kick start the economy
you know what funny fathers did to start
the economy uh they printed their own
Colonial script you know what Hitler did
when he wanted to start the economy but
had no goal he printed his own money
okay what happens when there is no money
we print them again and start the
economy all over again how hard is it to
comprehend
foreign
now would you like to have this fellow
for an economist you know running the
country
yeah these people think that because you
replace green money with brown money you
solve the problem
and they don't realize that you know uh
I mean just giving you an example take
take some of these billionaires like
Trump or you know uh Gates or whoever uh
you know now they change the money what
what will happen to their Holdings you
know I mean they have all these uh
properties and and bank accounts and
Investments suddenly you change the
money and that they lose everything
or or you know or the government itself
you know it's got debts uh suddenly all
those debts get wiped out because
they're not in green money now now
you've switched over to Brown money so
you don't owe the creditors a penny
you know I mean uh and let me give you
another example you know I mean why
don't the governments of the world every
government
just give every person on the planet a
million dollars
now that would solve a lot of people's
problems
right give everybody a million dollars
man that would solve everybody's problem
why don't we do it I mean if money is
just money and money is just money you
know we changed green money with brown
money let's give everybody money that
solves the problem apparently right
think about it
anyways uh here are people who have a
better hit on their heads and on their
shoulders and
um this is what they say about what's
coming in the next in the coming months
right in the next few months here it is
here's Jeff Bezos he says the economy
does not look good right now
things are slowing down you're seeing
layoffs in many many sectors of the
economy and that means you might want to
tighten up your budget and it says if
you're an individual considering
purchasing blah blah blah blah blah uh
you may want to wait a while okay and so
he uh he suggests that you wait because
things are not looking good and I guess
he should know he's you know up there
with your lead right it's probably as
many would think part of the new world
order right uh the Illuminati whatever
you know so I mean he's telling you
uh you know grab a hold of your money in
other words don't spend right now not a
good time to spend okay because bad
things are coming and here's another
source on investment uh uh
outfit you know
Investopedia four ways to hedge against
the next recession meaning you know when
they talk about recession if it's not
almost coming it's imminent right
there's a growing belief among
economists at 2023 could be the year
that the U.S spins into full-blown
recession
and they add recessions don't last
forever
uh yeah they could be followed by
depressions and as I see it uh that is
usually or the next depression will be
followed by Extinction
okay so they don't last forever these
people suggest that we're going back to
normal in the in the future and
you know you may want to think about
that uh are we coming back to normal
after the next recession especially with
this war going on you know in Ukraine
and there is a um
got a little article here where is it
I think it's this one yeah
it says d-u-e-u European union
outpostpones talks on oil price cap as
divisions stake there are differences
between the different countries in
Europe they don't know whether to put it
a a money cap you know a dollar cap on
oil coming from Russia
and they s and the reason they didn't
reach an agreement they think that maybe
if they do or some of these countries
think that if they do put a cap
it could damage the global economy
so we got that on top of you know the
fact that we already have or are moving
into a recession okay so maybe
uh counting our chickens at this point
so to speak right
here's another problem he's a little
more dressy he says top Economist uh El
Aryan says we're not just headed for
another recession but a profound
economic and financial shift and these
are all experts I mean you can call them
experts they're up there you might say
well there are no Ash birds that you
know better okay fine but these are the
people who uh who other people listen to
and so if these people are doomsayers
you know then maybe you might want to
listen to them it says a recession
occurs when a business cycle reaches its
natural end point and before the next
cycle really takes life but he said you
know this Valley Aryan the next cycle uh
said this time won't be one more turn of
the economic wheel as he sees the world
experiencing major changes that will
Outlast the current business cycle
is uh the re recession going to be
followed by a depression that's the
question for you maybe it gets worse and
not better okay
not that I'm saying it well but if I had
to bet uh I'd bet on that side not on
the side that we're going to recover
especially with this war going on over
there you know I think that's just going
to make matters work
and here we have another palette says uh
I believe the economy is the biggest
bubble in world history says Rich Dad
Poor dads Robert Kiyosaki God have mercy
on us all please don't listen to what
I'm going to say next I would get out of
paper Assets in other words money
you know like bills currency okay the
world economy is not a market I believe
the economy is the biggest bubble in
world history God have mercy on us all
and I more or less see it the same way I
think we're headed not only to a recess
uh recession but probably to a
depression and I'm not sure if we're
going to come out of that
so keep in mind what this site says
we're due for extinction it's going to
be caused by the collapse of the global
economy these people are saying we're
going to have a global problem economic
problem and so maybe you should start
sleeping with one eye open okay uh wimpa
has a solution he says we got in we
don't stop increasing population
or find some new energy right power
source right the Earth will no longer be
able to sustain humans okay he thinks
it's a question of you know the fact
that we have too much population it just
continues to increase we've got to stop
it
uh you know actually you know
population is already dwindling I guess
he's not aware of that in other words
our growth rate is falling and it's
falling for several reasons among them
that we've moved to the cities
and what happens then is density
dependent birth rates take over that's
the mode in which we're producing the
new generations the new people the new
children okay and so we're all ready he
doesn't have to worry about stopping
increase in population it's already
happening okay in fact uh it's one of
the big problems on the one hand because
if you don't produce population you
don't produce demand if you don't
produce demand corporations have to shut
their doors and they shut their doors
there's more unemployment and the cycle
continues
because then people don't earn money so
they postpone or don't have children at
all and again the cycle is just a a
wheel there okay we're not gonna
populate the planet so don't worry in
fact countries like Japan and Russia are
already on the decline they don't even
know how to get people in there because
they don't have any immigration and
Europe all of Europe Western Europe and
you United States Australia Canada and
all these countries they would be a
negative population growth just like
everybody else if it weren't for
immigration okay it's immigration that's
fueling the the population growth and
the economic growth and a lot of these
Advanced Nations without that
uh they be their economy would be
suffering let alone their population
numbers
uh but after he says a lot of stuff he
says unlikely we go extinct
so we have all these problems but we
won't go extinct but he doesn't say why
we're going to avoid extinction because
he probably doesn't know how Extinction
happens okay and that's why you know I
say always you know we got to do 101
Extinction 101 before Extinction 102. so
some people think that going back to
hunter-gatherers will solve the problem
it will only make it worse why
because for a few thousand people to
cook stay warm they would need a lot of
trees every day to sustain themselves so
he thinks this is a question of uh you
know
um defogia Gene environment you know
cutting the trees down
this is the way these people think no
it's got nothing to do with that let me
tell you what's going to happen if
uh you know we go to Hunter Gathering
first of all there's nothing to hunt our
dads are out there okay I mean do you
see wildebeest running on the highway
that you can hunt with your bow and
arrow or your gun or whatever your knife
spear
no there's there's nothing to hunt
so you would have to go to the forest
and uh compete you know with the bears
and wolves maybe for a deer and maybe
hunt them as well you know but then at
some point you know we're eight billion
people
and you know there are not enough wolves
uh Bears uh deer whatever to keep us
afloat so forget about hunting anyone
who's thinking of hunting you know
should think twice in fact uh I I've got
a little
uh summary here you know survivalist
without a cause it's just a caveman
survivalists are people who plan to hunt
after you know whatever comes our way
comes our way
and the prepper is a gardener you know
he's without a cause he's just a
Gardener He's a person who thinks he's
gonna you know plow the land after
everyone's gone
you know and he's gonna live I guess
forever you know reproduce
uh with uh uh genes that are already
wiped out
and with whom he's probably these guys
are probably Hermits the only way you're
going to survive if you're in a big
family group you know someone people who
have you know a lot of confidence in
each other but if you're a Hermit you
know it's just going to live out your
life and it's the same thing as if you
went extinct you just go extinct a
little later than everybody else that's
all but uh the big problem is you know
when the [ __ ] hits the fan you know this
could be the problem the problem is
going to be defense
you know you're going to be a farmer by
day and a soldier by night you're going
to have to defend whatever you plow out
there
and good luck with that one you know you
got all these people from the cities
coming to sharing your bounty
you're gonna be shooting a lot of people
I don't think they'll understand you
know when they're stomachs is stomachs
are completely empty and I don't think
they'll understand you know that you can
say let me teach you how to plant
you know there's no time for that
it's easier to steal believe me we did
in the past we're gonna do it in the
future okay so everybody's on their own
when the Kaka hits the fan
okay here's a couple people who think
that humans are different than animals
he says this vowel says your analysis
misses the qualitative difference
between humans and animals we're not
we're not animals okay we're humans
please don't call me an animal
humans are going extinct in a uniquely
human fashion well I don't know what he
meant by that he didn't put down how he
plans to have us go extinct and again I
don't think he has the slightest clue
okay another fellow along the same lines
he says over the Millennia and in the
billions of humans who lived and died in
humanity by its nature organized itself
and went from hunting to feed itself to
manufacturing synthetic meat in the
laboratory defeat itself while the whale
the shark etc etc always do the same
things
okay again it looks like you're saying
that we're not like those animals we're
different we evolved we we invented
things we we moved around we you know we
changed things and the animals oh you
did the same thing you know the cow
always eats grass every day and doesn't
complain
you eat grass every day see if you
complain
man on the other hand by his nature does
always does always different things
which show its Evolution over the
Millennia okay
um I don't think this fellow knows
um that you know there there's uh the
cat World I'll just give one example and
that's the cat World okay and you have
these cats you have uh these solitary
cats like the Jaguar the tiger the Puma
right
uh Mountaineer and then you have the
Lions and the lions are the only ones
that have Prides you know uh they have
families they live in in a group
and all these animals descended from the
same cat sometime you know a long time
ago okay
so they say about six million years ago
and uh I thought the smell says that
animals don't evolve well apparently the
alliance uh
invented something different than all
the other cats they became social
animals
so to say that animals do everything the
same way for always I mean the Beavers
always make little houses in the river
maybe you can go back in time there was
a development an evolution of the beaver
and they you know suddenly they started
building houses or slowly they figured
it out you know so to say that man is
the only animal that evolved and changed
and Etc
um think again look for examples before
you open your mouth
okay uh here's another phone he says
it's global warming that's going to kill
us the exponential function of global
warming will be the end of us
we have a guy Mark fears in there here's
something fearsome guy and he's a
chicken little
he thinks it's uh you know it's going to
be global warming that's going to kill
us and you have Al Gore and Greta
sunberg and they go around preaching the
gospel of climate change
climate change never
killed a single uh uh species on Earth
climate change does not kill species but
you know it'd be nice if these people
would tell us what the mechanism is you
know how does climate change get rid of
us how does it wipe Humanity out
okay that's what I need to understand
and all these people talk about climate
change whether it occurs or not is is
irrelevant or we'll concede that it's
happening okay no problem the question
is if it's happening please tell me how
that ends in the extinction of humanity
okay that's what you got to explain that
mechanism you know please please work on
that okay don't just say climate change
is going to kill us and we're done now
to buy a long shot
in fact uh it's never happened climate
change never did anything to anybody uh
the oh well I'll take that back climate
change only serves to favor whoever
comes next
okay so whenever the dinosaurs uh
disappeared the tiny mammals that were
in the waiting in the wings and expanded
with the angiosperms or the flowering
plants they radiated and I think climate
helped some species evolve faster than
other species in other words if it was
warm maybe it helped these animals it
was cold it helped those other animals
and those other plants that in that
sense yeah I think climate plays a a
function a a role an important role only
in radiation
post-master mass extinction but it
doesn't cause the extinction of species
or or of uh you know a whole mass
extinction it doesn't cause that
okay so here's another problem he says
human instrumentality project is
basically real the elites know we're
goners and I don't know what that human
instrumentality project was so I had to
look it up it's got to do with anime
some
uh
uh you know these people get their
their education you know in Hollywood
you know okay Hollywood University and
so they look at these things they get
these ideas you know about a futuristic
world and Anime is uh you know since
it's made by Japanese it's very uh
gloomy okay gloomy doomy okay
uh that's why in general my notion of
the Japanese lots of suicides over there
so you know it's a it's a country that's
reached its maximum uh development and
I'm not sure what uh you can expect from
them from in the future okay so yeah
some kind of uh instrumentality project
uh not important at all as far as I'm
concerned okay just um
the people who think that in this
world where they're in the streets and
everything's you know everything's dark
and here you have the the the couple
that's trying to survive in this new
world Etc you know there's a lot of uh
uh
novel it's a novel but very little on
science very little on analysis and
always always always no matter which one
of these uh movies you or cartoons that
you see or watch uh what you will never
see is anyone addressing food
you know you have like water world it's
like you know where does the food come
from
and uh you know you see all these movies
these Extinction movies and they never
talk about food it's like you know it's
uh some disease or some agent and it
never ends in the extinction by the way
there's always a baby at the end to give
Humanity hope okay okay so here we have
uh I made a comment the other day that
measures Clipper a long time to
Extinction and I said uh no more babies
uh you we have to found new cities and
shift labor to Agriculture and again I
don't think this ever gonna happen I'm
saying that it would be nice in an ideal
world where everybody on Earth you know
realize that we're due for extinction we
say okay we're intelligent how how can
we fix this problem how can we prolong
our lives so that Extinction doesn't hit
us so quickly and these are the
suggestions I'm saying that you know
people would have to zero in on in order
to extend their lives for Humanity as a
whole right and as if we all all
Cooperative we all loved each other you
know if all the governments you know
were you know were had no politicians no
no uh lawyers you know no if we were all
you know Buddhist or whatever you know
Hindus and embraced each other well this
is maybe what we should do and this is
the only thing I can think of that could
prolong our lives but a couple people
say why would you want to do that you
know prolong our life another fellow
says why would we want to people stink
convid taught us that
okay I guess he misspelled covid right
okay so um uh here's another fell along
the same lines he says uh so you're
saying a maoist land reform could work
laugh out loud why not babies though I
don't quite understand that are you
saying Humanity should reproduce slower
to make the genetic diversity last
longer or just letting it be the last
generation
oh I'm saying that you know if you look
at the map it's uh terrible uh we we're
concentrated in cities you know if you
look at the world it's mostly urbanized
and becoming more and more urbanized
that means we're expanding the existing
centers and I'm saying there's a lot of
free land out there be nice if by some
miracle God's miracle type thing that we
could induce people to leave the cities
go to the middle of nowhere in the
middle of the desert right in the middle
of the forest jungle wherever and found
new cities so they create this new city
right whatever they've got there if they
do primarily agriculture they're
creating real stuff right and hopefully
they can become self-sustaining even
export you know whatever but the idea is
to create more cities but then at the
same time I think we should stop
procreating because
uh the more we procreate and the more we
stay in the cities that's bad we should
go out into the country and the existing
people should go there and stop
procreating only because you know uh we
realize under this context okay the
context is important here we realize
that we're the last humans on Earth why
are we going to produce more and more
children
okay the idea would be to limit now the
number of children that we have in the
in the world so that whoever is Young
today just grows old okay and we all try
to live together kiss each other be
friends and family Etc uh of course I'm
talking about a world that doesn't exist
I don't even think it exists in heaven
okay but I mean this is what I'm
suggesting that's my solution my 10
cents were of course it's not going to
happen but I'd say that that would be an
ideal world where we say what could be a
solution solution would be to found new
cities in the middle of nowhere and do
it with the existing people
that's my point okay okay and so I
always recommend that we do Extinction
101 before you do Extinction 102.
everybody wants the dehuman extinction
everybody's an expert in human
extinction of why man won't die or why
he will die and he will die in
gazillions of years in the future so we
don't have to worry about it no please
do Extinction 101 find out how
Extinction occurred in the past in the
days of the dinosaurs in the days of the
Triassic arcosars in the days of the
Permian mammal-like reptiles once you
figure that out and you can tell me
exactly how all those animals
disappeared then we can talk about human
extinction okay so that we can
extrapolate whatever you found in those
days to humans and see if we can uh
overcome
whatever they couldn't
okay let's move on to the subject matter
of today and that is particle what is a
particle does anybody know you know I've
been uh searching for this uh thing
called particle Quantum particle okay
we're going to talk about Quantum Parco
by the way okay and maybe that's where
we should start here we have uh the
notion that laymen have about what
particles are okay and I guess they
extrapolate them or most of them
apparently extrapolate them to quantum
mechanics and it's the classical
particle and what is that well it's a
grain of sand a seed a speck of dust
tiny ball corpuscle that's what we used
to call them right
and right now Quantum particle the
answer you get from the phds the Nobel
Prize winners and all these other good
people we don't know so please don't ask
you say Bill you're kidding me
no no I'm not kidding you I'm gonna
prove that to you today I'm going to
show you some evidence okay evidence
proof okay I'm gonna show you today that
that's exactly
what the phds are telling you please
don't ask because we have no clue
whatsoever
please hold your particle is a particle
I mean we represented in in the old days
Right In classical uh physics meaning
anything be low 19 19th century and
Below right and I was a DOT the ball is
a spot you know uh point you would hit
the board with your chalk you make a
little white dot and say that's a point
and what is that that's a particle and
everybody would understand you could
explain your theory by saying look that
dot now moves over here moves over there
and I can explain this motion that
motion that's more or less how it went
and it turns out that Quantum explains
it the same way except that they tell
you that they don't know what it is no
longer do they say it's a grain of sand
or a tiny ball in fact they specifically
tell you in your face it ain't
it's not one of those
so don't insist we don't know
okay that's the answer you get today and
so we say well holy how difficult can
this be
uh so let's look it up first to see if
there's some kind of definition out
there you know for what a particle is
here's one definition it comes from a uh
Source a trusted Source right dams
glossary of meteorology
and aggregation of sufficiently many
atoms or molecules that it can be
assigned macroscopic prior properties
such as volume density pressure and
temperature
now how's that for for an answer so it's
a bunch of particles right forms I guess
a ball uh this this is what I
Illustrated maybe it's a cube I don't
know but I Illustrated that as a ball
and a particle is just a bunch of
particles okay that's what it is
okay okay did you understand particle is
a bunch of particles okay that's great
okay let's see if we have any other uh
version here we have the Wikipedia as
always we should use uh primary sources
that uh all these phds put their
two cents worth in there and then they
later disclaim and say well don't trust
the Wikipedia because it's got all these
terrible definitions turns out that all
those are made by phds especially in the
world of so-called physics mathematical
physics okay so this is what you find in
the physical science a particle or
corpuscle corpuscle is a particle I
thought it wasn't
in older text is a small localized
object
so they're saying that the so-called
particle is a small
corpuscle or object
okay so keep that in mind okay this is
what the encyclopedia tells you okay
to which can be ascribed you know
several properties great okay and so you
look uh up this and you look up for
example Elementary fundamental particle
and says one that is not made of
components so it's I guess made of a
single piece okay
uh we'll keep that in mind as well okay
but then you look at uh you know what do
they mean by objects there's localized
object a collection of matter what is
matter any substance that has mass takes
up space okay great
what is so substance it's matter
anything that has mass and taste of
space okay what is a chemical substance
a material meaning matter what is mass
quantity of matter what a space well we
still have no idea today at mathematical
physics right has no idea
so we don't learn much with these
definitions because they use the word
object and they use the maybe they might
use the word entity right to depict or
Define the particle
and now they're wrong it's it's not an
object we'll see that today okay not a
thing
and that's why they tell you that they
don't know what it is okay
here we have an article
uh was uh from uh 2020 I think it is let
me get this smaller and it was from the
quantum magazine and these people give
me a second here these people uh say
that uh ask the question what is a
particle and they didn't just ask it
they decided to ask all the so-called
physicists mathematical physicists okay
and give me one more second here
okay and it says what are particles the
easy answer quickly shows itself to be
unsatisfying
what a bad way to start your
presentation it says uh I'm not going to
be able to tell you yeah okay electrons
photons quarks and other fundamental
particles supposedly lag substructure or
physical extent
so
it's an object that has no shape no no
size
no diameter no radius no nothing there's
nothing there
you can't illustrate this so-called
particle and none of these electrons
photons quarks because they have no size
what are you going to put in there you
can't put a dot
and say well assume this is the electron
you know I can't make that assumption
because you just told me it has no size
why did you put a dot
you put a heart to represent love
you put a dot to represent point or if
you do you're making a big
error okay okay and yet particles have
distinct traits such as charge and mass
how can a dimensionalist point right
bear weight
yeah good question
so uh this lady decided to investigate
this issue and ask all the let me see if
I can get this out ask all these uh phds
and high-level phds in so-called
mathematical physics what is a particle
I mean if they don't know who does
right okay so here are the answers she
got
okay and she went to different places
you'll see who the authors of these
answers were okay here we have them
first one we basically think of a
particle as a point-like object again
set the same thing as before okay is
that what a particle is okay let's use
it what's the problem
if it's a point like object meaning you
know it's got shape because it's an
object it's got size it's got dimensions
it's got all these good things uh why uh
were they saying that it has none
you know and then it says what we think
of as Elementary particles again when
that is not broken up into simpler parts
right instead might be vibrating strings
so we have an elementary particle which
is not made of anything which has no
size no Dimensions right and uh but
that's a vibrating string whatever
string is and what is a string made of
well it's made out of particles because
the string is not a string it's a line
it's a curved line what is a line that's
made out of dots points uh what I call
in Geometry points locations
positions as the mathematicians call it
that's what what a string is a string is
not a physical entity it's a
mathematical
Contraption you can't even call it a
Contraption because that word is wrong
there as well no it's just uh it's a
mathematical abstraction that would be
better to say it's a line and a line of
geometry a line of mathematics is made
out of points which are locations
positions right and uh means that we're
not talking about things
we're talking about
uh dots that represent Concepts
okay so we are reifying the string and
they say that the string when it
vibrates is a particle so a particle is
not a standalone thing you can't take a
snapshot of a particle because the
string has to vibrate in order to make
up the particle all kinds of errors with
that statement there okay and that was
by Mary Gaylord uh particle theory is
that you see Berkeley
okay that was the first one let's see if
we have any more we have another
volunteer here
my name is Helen Quinn and she's went
and Meredith's professor at Stanford she
says the following says what is a
particle from a physicist point of view
it's a Quantum excitation of a field
okay so it turns out that the particle
is something in motion that's what makes
up the particle they call that something
a field
so we have a field it vibrates and as
long as it's vibrating we have a
particle
so a particle is not a standalone you
can't take a snapshot of a particle
because you get you have to wait for the
field to vibrate there's got to be a
verb in there you know and so you need
two frames of the universal movie to
make a particle
which is kind of weird you know
and uh we look up the word uh field and
so quantity represented by a number that
has value for each point in space in
Space the point in space and time
so again we're talking about a number
the number vibrates and as long as the
number vibrates we have a particle if
the number stops vibrating I guess it's
the number five
could be could be the number seven so if
the number seven stops vibrating we no
longer have a particle
you figure it out
it says in that there are a bunch of
different fields each field has
different properties and excitations
they are different depending on the
properties those excitations we can
think of as a particle that was our
answer
PhD what emeritus
okay these are these are the teachers
that you're paying for in in some of
these schools because a lot of them are
government supported
okay here's a Nobel Prize winner I mean
you got to pay attention now for sure
okay because the other two they were not
Nobel Prize it's just a petty Emeritus
and uh so-called physics teacher this
one's a Nobel Prize Shelby glass shop
okay particles are at a very minimum
described by irreducible representations
of the pancare group okay the
representation is not the particle
uh-huh
the representation is a way of
describing certain properties of the
particle
okay so we're talking about descriptions
of a particle I wanted to know what a
particle is that you could point to it
and say that's a particle yes you can't
do it and let us not confuse the two
yeah here you have a PhD
who got his uh no prize
in quantum mechanics we're coming up
with some little idea in quantum
mechanics and he can't tell you what a
particle is and quantum mechanics is a
particle theory
and it's got the standard model of
particles
and as well he cannot tell you what a
particle is
but he he was given a Nobel Prize by his
buddies right
makes you stop and think right here
Nobel Prize doesn't know what a particle
is how difficult can it be it used to be
the famous corpuscle that you know
Newton had in the back of his mind and
all these other people all the way to
the 19th century they thought of it as a
little dot a little uh ball
you'll see a little grain of sand
we all understood that but now you know
they're talking about what Fields
vibrating Fields vibrating numbers
that's what a particle is
and they take it back and say we don't
know what it is what did you just say
you said it's a vibrating field now you
say well we don't know what it is
okay so it's getting better and better
every moment here's another uh testimony
take these people to court right uh
Dimitri nanopoulos particle physicist is
at Texas A M okay Aggies
uh if you zoomed in enough on particles
you would see not points but
one-dimensional vibrating strains again
another strength here is here what is
this thing I mean God is better than
this yeah you're telling me particles
are what we measure in detectors at the
moment that I detect it it collapses the
wave and becomes a particle the particle
is the collapsed wave function
the collapse wave function
what in the world is that now see if I
think I have it here uh
no I don't okay I have to skip that one
but uh the point is it's a wave function
collapse
so here we have a field that that
vibrates that's what a particle is here
this is the collapse of the wave
function function is an equation that's
uh you know it's a
it's a formula a mathematical equation
and they're saying this thing is going
to collapse
so I I can't imagine how a wave function
can collapse what sense does that make
what meaning can that have
okay I don't have any answers for you
there anyways uh here's another
testimony another witness comes to the
court and it says the following
says uh particles are what we measure in
detectors we start slipping into
language of saying that it's the quantum
fields that are real and particles are
excitations okay that's how they present
it to you right we uh we talk about
virtual particles yeah whatever those
are virtual means that they come out of
the magic wand of the uh magician math
magician
but it doesn't go click click click in
anyone's detector
okay yeah I mean you have all these
so-called particles uh virtual particles
the elementary particles and what they
say is we don't know what it is but as
long as they go tick tick tick on the
detector then we call it a particle and
some of them you know come in from the
void because we have to make them up you
know
uh you figure out
Jesus Christ
and here you have another fellow he just
says shut your mouth don't don't ask
okay don't ask don't tell okay we say
they are fundamental but that just a way
of to say to students don't ask I don't
know the answer
it's fundamental don't ask anymore okay
at least that was a more honest answer I
think you know than all these people who
claim to know what a particle is you
know and they say it's a vibrating field
it's a way to function collapse and
these people say look don't ask we have
no clue and uh here's another phone from
MIT uh says at the end of the day
quantum gravity has some mathematical
structure and we're all chipping away at
it good if it's got
structure fine but mathematical
structure that's like saying it's an
abstract
structure abstract physicality like
that's an oxymoron you know mathematical
structure a quantum theory of gravity
and space time will ultimately be needed
to answer the question what are the
fundamental building blocks of the
Universe on its most fundamental scales
a more sophisticated phrasing of the
question what is a particle yeah but see
they never asked that question
mathematics because they have no use for
objects all they have used for is
equations and numbers and measurements
and values quantities
so yeah it ends the
presentation saying we don't have uh we
don't know is the short answer
they don't know so please do not ask
that question of a mathematical Fez as
is okay they have no clue
okay so when they tell you look it's a
wave function collapse it's a vibrating
field say okay but what is it can you
drive for me can you point to it
and hopefully the the guy in front of
you will not say please don't ask me
again
okay so here are the conclusions folks
we have uh not a single mathematician on
Earth can tell you what a Quantum
particle is I mean is it a physical
object or not if it's Zero Dimensional
point or whatever however they want to
describe it we have a nothing in front
of us so you can't say at the same time
that it's also a vibrating field and
also the wave function collapse you
can't have all these versions
the correct answer is they don't know
please don't ask again okay that's the
answer so a Quantum particle is not a
tiny ball Quantum particle is a location
with a value
that's what the mathematicians deal with
so quantum mechanics does not have
particles meaning corpuscles you know
tiny balls okay
it is universally designated represented
with a DOT everybody puts a DOT chalk on
the board pencil on a paper you know Etc
it's just a DOT and that dot is a is a
physical entity you see it's
two-dimensional at least and you look at
it and say okay is that what a particle
is okay I see it's just a tiny ball
that's not what you're staring at they
they already fooled you they put a thing
to represent a concept
and you didn't catch it okay so the word
particle and the pictorial dot mislead
Layman into thinking that the quantum
particle is a thing it ain't okay
Quantum does not deal with things
okay so you cannot describe
or explain especially the uh the
universe in which we live especially the
sub Micron uh subatomic World Atomic and
subatomic world this is not a Quantum
particle okay so anyone who tells you
differently uh he's lying okay so don't
believe them and so here's the standard
model uh quantum mechanics okay what do
you see there well you see all these
so-called particles they call them
particles Elementary particles particles
made of a single piece in other words
that are not made of smaller components
and it's interesting that they haven't
found the graviton they've been
searching for that one for ages okay
they haven't found a graviton
and that's the particle of gravity they
will never find it because you cannot
explain pull with gravitons it also is
even if they did find its uh
inconsistent or incompatible with
general relativity which talks about
extended fields and canvases I guess you
could call them so yeah none of those
are particles uh in the sense of how we
imagine a particle a little tiny Speck
of dust in fact you can see that there
are no pictures of any of the so-called
particles and they have little drawings
with a little h on top or a little C or
whatever on top of them and that's what
they consider a particle
they have no idea in other words they're
going to talk about traces and they're
going to talk about
um wave functions and we're going to
talk about fields and those are not
defined either at least in any physical
sense
so you will never know you will never
understand what a particle is in Quantum
and so the particle model in fact they
should use a different word
they should call it the collapse or the
vibrating field or whatever instead of
calling it a particle particle is a
misleading word okay and it's just there
to fool you
okay uh we had our science critic okay
and what did he talk about well he
talked about studying and originally he
said uh he he made a video by the way a
45 minute video uh talking about uh the
scientific method criticizing the
scientific method and so uh we address
each one of the points that he raised
and especially uh today we're going to
talk about studying he insinuated in a
previous uh uh talk that um science is
about studying and here we're going to
say that it ain't in fact we're going to
find out that he absolutely agrees with
us okay so let me put him on so he's uh
you hear from the horse's mouth himself
okay here it goes
the question to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
is a scientist someone who studies
just so that everyone's aware that but
this is to study all night is just an
example of it being used in a sentence
well just because you study something
that doesn't mean that you're a
scientist I have studied computers and
audio that does not make me a scientist
and also devoting time to gaining
knowledge does not guarantee the
retention of that knowledge I think
anyone who has set an exam can attest to
that nowhere in the definition of
studying did it say that you have to do
it by reading books it just said that
that's the typical way that it is done
okay so um that was irrelevant that last
statement uh the fact that uh you have
to do it by reading books uh he
suggested doing experiments and studying
in your own dark basement etc etc none
of that has anything to do with science
in fact uh here uh and he seems to agree
because he says that just by studying
you will not learn
and he's totally right that is the
problem with using the word study to
define the word science okay that was
the issue here you have some Sciences
the first one I'll mention is biology
okay biology what is it the scientific
study of life that's the official
definition no it's not the study of
anything in science we do not study okay
you can study all you want doesn't mean
that you're going to understand in fact
there you see it studying you can study
but you fail on the test
okay and um so what's the issue the
issue is science a systematic Endeavor
that builds and organizes knowledge in
the form of testable explanations and
predictions about the universe that's
the scientific part of biology's
definition okay and you look at these
words Endeavor what is it attemptable
achieve okay you're going to make an
attempt at something
uh is that what science is making
attempts at achieving
hopefully science is after the fact uh
when you have achieved already and what
you have to achieve is explanations
uh knowledge it's belief okay that's
what's defined as Justified true belief
testable explanations what the hell is
that uh in science we have explanations
testable means that uh you're working on
belief
yeah you're harping on religion you're
saying do you believe it
because you tested something and you
decided to believe it or not believe it
yeah prediction well I don't know what
that has to do with science that's
astrology and palm reading they do
predictions over there foretelling you
know they can tell you the day that you
were born if he's a good astrologer or
or he looked at your you know driver's
license or something
Universe uh what is that it's time
energy mass and Fields and other
mathematical Concepts that's what the
definition of
Universe means to
us uh you know follows through on that
on those definitions so yeah biology the
scientific
uh I don't know what that is a
scientific study no in science we don't
study and in life as I discussed in the
past there is no definition of the word
Life coming from emanating from the
biology World okay so that we don't have
a single biologist on planet Earth
because not one can Define
his uh
discipline his uh realm of expertise
okay has no clue whatsoever Okay so
until they can Define the word life
um and if biology is the study of life
right as they say well first it's not
the study but then they don't know what
life is so so much for biology okay
let's see if some of the others do any
better here we have um
now where is it here paleontology okay
oh I got the same one
well let's see if I get uh
give me a second here get the one from
uh paleontology there we go
hey that's the one for paleontology the
scientific study of life that existed
prior to the start of the Holocene Epoch
uh roughly 11 700 years before the
present it includes the study always
that word study of fossils to classify
organisms and study the interactions
with each other in their environments
okay so they use the word study study
study study is it just study is that
what paleontology is
no paleontology is not the study in
paleontology you have to explain if you
don't explain you're not a scientist
you're not a paleontologist and no it's
not you know Indiana Jones with this
little pick and uh Digging Up Bones
that's not paleontology either that's uh
that's a field worker
could be uh you know
one of these uh Bean Pickers out there
that you know picks uh beans or
strawberries you know in California uh
are they a paleontologists because they
dig okay so no just digging it does not
make you a palliant in cleaning bones
right does not make you a paleontologist
naming them does not make you
paleontologists paleontologist does one
thing and one thing only and that's
explain Extinction
if you cannot explain Extinction in a
rational manner you are not a
paleontologist I'm sorry okay and so far
we have no paleontologists on Earth
first because they do study which or
they can't Define their own uh
discipline but then uh they have all
these irrational theories of mass and
background extensions so we don't have a
single valid theory of Extinction today
until we do we don't have
paleontologists I guess right
okay and then uh the last one here is
physics okay the natural science that
studies
I do a lot of studying studies what
matter
it's fundamental constituents its motion
and behavior through space and time and
the related entities of energy and force
let's look up those words matter any
substance that has mass and takes up
space what is motion an object changes
and etc etc and what has changed
different from what it is or to
transform which in all cases involves
motion meaning the word change is a
synonym of motion you can't use the word
change to define the word motion okay
space what is space the boundless
three-dimensional it's three-dimensional
extent
I don't know what an extent is but
certainly space is not three-dimensional
okay hopefully not
uh space has no Dimensions whatsoever it
is a synonym of nothing what is time
continued sequence of existence and
events
aha I guess uh it's got to go to the
Future right which uh they say in the
definition but that would take time
because uh future is already a
definition of time okay in other words
you need time to Define future so we got
a circular argument there and that is it
says is something no kidding good okay
energy energy is an entity the
quantitative property it says
so how can they say the entities of
energy and force force what is an
influence
sounds like a verb
so we have the quantity a quantitative
property
and an influence
so none of those words help to Define
physics at all so yeah in a way uh this
shows that all these definitions of
these disciplines uh they're
misconceived
that's one issue the other one is that
no we don't study in science
and so this fellow saying that uh
science is the study of because that's
the definition he found out there well
you know all those definitions have to
be wiped from the dictionary
okay okay let's get to some of the
questions people ask since last time
they posted or comments one of the
definitions of science is knowledge of
any kind
absolutely not we have only one
definition of Science and that's
rational explanations if it's not
rational we don't care
uh you know how much knowledge you have
um knowledge has nothing to do with
anything aside from the fact that the
word knowledge has never been defined
other than as belief that's what
knowledge is is a personal belief that's
all it is that's all knowledge when you
know
nobody can change your mind it's because
you believe it so strongly that it's
like a strong belief that's all
knowledge is and that's personal that's
uh your personal opinion and that has to
do with religion religion deals with
opinions okay so now uh we don't care
what what one of the millions of
definitions of science is out there
there's only one and that is rational
explanations you don't have a rational
explanation you are not a scientist okay
the word plasma is knowledge of again
knowledge no has nothing to do with
knowledge plasma there it is ionized gas
that's what plasma means actions of that
Plasma in the Photosphere as coronal
mass ejection solar wind where it meets
the inner Galactic plasma is traveling
around the Galaxy you have plasma
traveling how can a concept travel
does love travel also in your religion
I mean you know these people especially
the electric universers they strongly
believe in plasma they are uh plasmoids
as we call okay no plasma is ionized gas
that's what the word plasma means ionize
is uh adjective or a verb really okay
there's motion involved in ionized
there's no such thing as static ionized
you need two frames of the universal
movie at least
to depict
ionized okay you can't depict ionized in
one
picture okay you can't show the ET
in one picture ionized whatever
okay any atom that's ionized needs two
two frames of the movie and uh what is
it being uh ionized gas gas is an object
is a thing okay why because you don't
need Motion in the definition of the
word gas in other words the word gas
does not involve a verb uh motion of any
kind the word plasma does that's the
difference between them gasostatic
plasma is not
okay so that's where these people and of
course they they never relinquish the
word plasma because their whole life
depends on this word plasma you kill
plasma you rape their virgin
you killed her God
so they're going to hang on to the word
plasma until the end of their days so
you can't take it away from there they
they're not understanding the logic and
they dismiss that as
um you know word salad uh semantics blah
blah blah no in science we have to
define the word so we know what we're
talking about we have to be on the same
page plasma is ionized gas that's what
it is sorry that you just found out and
uh ionized gas gas meaning you know just
a bunch of atoms
they're not bound as strongly as other
objects like you know a table or a chair
that's a solid right a rock
so those don't move as much as the ones
in a gas or in the liquid but it's
irrelevant the motion is irrelevant I
can take a picture of gas and call it
gas because gas the word gas does not
embody an emotion
the word gas does not embody an emotion
do you understand the word gas does not
embody any motion yes the electrons are
moving around every single atom in the
universe
okay so don't tell me that the electrons
are moving no we take a snapshot and in
the snapshot in the picture in the still
image in the frame of the movie in just
one frame of the movie there's nothing
moving in that picture Okay God uh just
cross takes a sword very thin sword
makes a cross section of time Across the
Universe stops the universe wherever
it's at nothing moves
okay except him
I guess nothing moves not a single
electron not a single atom nothing moves
okay
gas is that blob that is Frozen in Time
there is no plasma that you you can't
point to Plasma in that cross-section of
time because plasma is defined it
embodies motion do you understand can
you get it through your thick skull
plasma involves motion
gas does not I don't know how else to
tell these people it's just they're just
so thick-headed that they'll never
understand okay anyways ionized is what
a gas does okay the gas is the object it
ionizes what it does that's what plasma
is so glass gas is a photo where plasma
is a movie and that's why you cannot use
a concept because it's a dynamic concept
called plasma you cannot use it as a
physical object and say plasma does this
and plasma moves and plasma went out of
the Sun and Intergalactic space not in
this universe okay
okay and then I think same fellow he
says plasma a state of matter see they
have these two definitions for plasma
one is ionized gas and the other one is
a state of the union or something like
that say it matters matter it doesn't
matter one of the four
including liquid solids and gases
so he's saying okay let's get it right
this fellow just like all electric
universes they think that a state of
matter such as a solid liquid and gas
uh you know those are not objects those
are not things if you say a solid that's
not a thing solid is a category
okay under solve this you can put you
know Furniture rocks trees solids
it's a category you can't say a solid is
a thing
okay and likewise if you're going to put
it in this context and say plasma is a
state of matter
then what you're saying is that plasma
is a category and therefore it's a
concept
okay it's a it's a type of matter
okay and that's not a thing
it's a concept okay I don't know how
else to get a three or six goal and
again all these people say Bill you're
doing you know word salad and uh
semantics
yeah we need to know what these words
mean so we can use them so uh
consistently so that we're all on the
same page so it's not word salad okay
and I'm not sure how else to drive it
through his head Maybe
little uh
hahaha
sometimes that works wonders yeah okay
anyways uh this kind of solid liquid and
gas and plasma are categories so no you
can't use the word plasma as a physical
object whether you use it as a state of
matter or as ionized gas either way it's
it's banned as a thing it's not a thing
there's no thing called plasma okay
plasma is a concept you need to learn
language before you learn physics okay
you need to take a English 101 grammar
101
okay so um here's another photo says
lightning has shape are you calling
lightning an object sound waves have
shame are you calling sound an object
magnetic fields have shape are you
calling a field an object okay
uh Fields energies and sunways have
shapes there are many examples of
physical pressure presence that have
shape but aren't objects
well I don't know
um uh
uh lightning I guess he's referring he
says lightening lightning is not a
physical object no it's not it has and
it doesn't have shape because lightning
is in motion like plasma is in motion
like electricity is in motion in fact oh
well I didn't realize that lightning is
electricity yeah of course and what is
electricity can you take a snapshot of
electricity no we take a snapshot of
some light there and we say that thing
is electricity it's lightning
no what you whether you know it or not
that's not electricity electricity is
defined as something in motion and so is
lightning
there is no such thing as lightning in a
single picture okay
uh you can take that as a flash of light
is that an object does that have shape
now if you call it lightning lightning
uh look it up it's uh it's got a it's
got a verb in it okay it's got Motion in
it and so there's a magnetic field any
field for that matter you know you have
motion okay so there's no such thing as
a static uh field
fields are all in motion now there's
something is in motion that makes up the
field and uh good old Mr maximum James
Maxwell he said there is matter in
Motion in there some exotic matter right
uh there's matter in motion what you
have to identify is the matter that's in
motion calling the whole shebang a field
something that's moving like plasma you
know I'm calling that a thing calling
that uh moving thing a field uh you
don't get away with that not in physics
you have to tell me what it is that's
moving and also in the case of
electricity or lightning there you have
to tell me what it is that is moving
because something is moving from up down
again they say oh it has shape no it
doesn't have shape shape is a static
concept lightning is not
okay so I don't know how else to explain
it to you if you don't understand it
look it up look up these words you'll
find out that uh you made a boo-boo you
spoke too soon
okay if all says
I don't have it here
give me a second here and see if I can
find it
uh there we go
an object is a collection of matter
that's what he says object is a
collection of atoms okay so we look at
matter any substance that has mass and
takes up space by having volume well
substance is already you know an object
okay so hopefully you know you're you're
you're trying to find the word object
and you're using the word matter which
is substance and substance is already an
object a synonym of object
objects that can be touched are
ultimately composed of atoms that's what
we find in out there in the Wikipedia
and so they're talking about touched so
if you can't touch them what they're not
composed of atoms like the table on the
other side of the universe that's not
composed of atoms and you say well it
can be touched well how do you know
I mean we can't even run the experiment
so how do you know it can be touched
okay so this is the issue in scientific
usage matter includes atoms and anything
made up of them okay so all they did was
go around in circles so to say that it's
a collection of matter we haven't said
anything because matter is already you
have to define the word object before
you define the word matter because
matter is a bunch of objects that's what
matter means so you can't use the word
matter to define object because you have
to define the word object before you
define the word matter and to say is a
collection of atoms well what is an atom
isn't that an object
so again these these people chasing
their tails around trying to beat the
definition and they're just going to go
nuts
and then you find in the dictionary.com
matter the substance again substance or
substances of which any physical object
consists of or is composed so uh again
there's talking about what they're
talking about mariology what something
is made out of
and physical or corporeal substance
something that occupies space okay so
again uh we're talking about synonyms
substance is something something an
object and matter is a bunch of objects
so far we have no definition from you
because all you used was synonyms just
chase Your Tail around
and here are another well I think the
same fellow there are four fundamental
forces that work in the universe the
strong weak electromagnetic and
gravitational
well there's only two forms of contact
that we can imagine
okay and that's push and pull
okay so you either pull or you push
that's it as far as uh you know forces
and
um you got to answer how uh the weak and
the electromagnetic force different from
push
they're both push forces and the strong
and the gravitational force forces uh
they're all pull forces so how are they
different if two of them are push and
two are above our pool
so that's what you got to answer so I
think maybe he was referring to not four
forces but maybe the four horses like
the apocalypse or something like that
yeah uh no four forces only in religion
and uh here's the last uh issue fellow
says looking at your graviton field how
exactly are your ropes different
that strange that he would say that's uh
maybe newbie but yeah the discreet
graviton field okay that's what Quantum
proposes they had a bunch of particles
discrete particles okay it's called they
call it they don't like to use the word
ether but that's what it is it's an
ether Quantum has the same thing as we
always had since the days of the Greek
and that's in mathematical physics right
and that's uh discrete particles and
what we're saying is something else
we're saying that all atoms are
physically interconnected
so we have discrete versus
interconnected
and that's all I can tell you that's if
you can't understand that there's no use
in going further with any questions with
you because until you understand this
difference you won't understand anything
okay so yeah Quantum discrete uh rope
hypothesis our proposal physically
interconnected that's the difference
right there and we can explain gravity
with that because we are connected we
just can't see the mediators in the case
of quantum they can't see them either
but they use words such as mass and who
knows what to try to explain
gravitational attraction
okay with that I'll see you next Sunday
and hopefully uh you had a great
Thanksgiving and we'll have a great
Christmas we'll see you there bye-bye